divorce se concrétise aussi dans
l'espace les russes les européens
devaient envoyer en septembre prochain
un rover sur mars mais la mission a été
suspendue ce jeudi par l' agence
spatiale européenne sylvain rousseau
bonjour jours la planète rouge attendra
donc oui effectivement on se doutait
remet maintenant depuis quelques
semaines depuis le début de la guerre et
même plus encore depuis le début des
sanctions que le rover rosalind franklin
du programme exomars du programme russo
européen exomars ne foulerait pas le sol
de la planète rouge on ne savait pas en
revanche s'il s'agit s'il s'agirait d'un
report d'une suspension ou d'une
annulation pure et simple et c'est
l'information qui nous a communiqué l'
agence spatiale européenne aujourd'hui
il s'agit donc d'une suspension et son
directeur général a été mandatée pour
trouver une solution le plus rapidement
possible pour relancer le programme
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
on est sur un programme qui a quand même
coûté 2 milliards d'euros sur un
programme qui dit que les européens ont
commencé il y a maintenant 20 ans et
c'est sans doute pour ça qu'il n'a pas
été annulée ce pas par rapport à tout le
travail qui a été fourni par rapport au
budget qui a déjà été dépensé on sait
que les russes sur cette mission devait
fournir le lanceur mais également
l'atterrisseur sur mars mais essentielle
essentiel de composantes vraiment oui
essentiel et surtout qui ne se fabrique
pas dans un délai aussi court on sait
que la fenêtre de lancement optimale
vers mars elle revient tous les 26 mois
qu'il ne dure qu'une dizaine de jours il
faut donc très bien calculé c'est
évidemment impossible de relancer le
programme pour 2022 c'est impossible de
relancer le programme pour la prochaine
fenêtre de 2024 les délais sont encore
trop court pour fabriquer un lanceur si
le programme est relancée ça sera donc
début d'année
2027 et peut-être même plus probablement
encore
2020 2029 en revanche on ne sait pas ce
que qu'elle rallonge budgétaire on va
devoir va devoir fête va devoir payer l'
agence spatiale européenne puisque il y
à des composants dans ce rover qui vont
devoir être remplacés soit parce qu'ils
vont devenir obsolètes soit parce qu'il
y aura de nouvelles technologies qui
vont apparaître comment va se dérouler
cette mission on ne le sait pas non plus
ça sera l'une des autres questions
auxquelles le directeur général va
devoir répondre soit on partira sur un
programme 100% européen donc lanceur et
atterrisseur européen soit sur un autre
partenaire à ce moment là il reste les
états unis ou la chine plus probablement
les états unis sachant que la nasa était
le premier partenaire des européens sur
ce programme jusqu'en 2012 qui l'ont
arrêté faute de budget c'est à ce moment
là que les européens se sont liés avec
les russes et les autres programmes de
coopération aussi ont du plomb dans l
aile oui effectivement c'est l'autre
partie du communiqué de l'agent spatiale
toutes les missions dont le lancement
est assurée par un vaisseau russe que ce
soit un soyouz où un proton depuis
baïkonour où depuis kourou sans pour
l'instant suspendu vous avez donc des
satellites européen de radionavigation
qui sont cloués au sol à kourou des
satellites de télécommunications
britannique qui sont sous scellés à
baïkonour que les russes ne veulent pas
lancé vous avez un satellite militaire
aussi france est dans le même cas
puisque oui les russes lancent aussi nos
satellites militaires vous avez des
moteurs d étage de fusée qui sont
fabriqués ou assemblés en russie ou en
ukraine pour des lanceurs européens ou
américains et quand ces pièces vont
commencer à manquer et bien un moyen
terme ces programmes là seront aussi
impactés et puis il ya évidemment le
plus emblématique de tous la station
spatiale internationale
on se rappelle des des menaces indus
dimitri rogozine le patron de l'agencé
spatiale russe en début de semaine où il
disait qu'avec les sanctions il ne
pourrait bientôt plus ré orbite et la
station spatiale et qu'elle risquait
donc de tomber de s'écraser sur la terre
on en est très loin pour l'instant
officiellement l'ambiance à bord est
toujours bonne demain doivent décoller
trois cosmonautes russes 9 qui décollé
de baïkonour pour rejoindre la station
spatiale il s'agit d'une relève qui
était prévu depuis deux depuis quelques
temps maintenant et aucune aucune
surprise là dedans et ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que et bien le
30 mars prochain puisqu'il y en a trois
qui mentent y en a trois qui descendent
vous avez les deux cosmonautes russes à
bord qui vont redescendre sur terre et
les russes vont assurer le retour comme
c'était prévu de l'astronaute américain
mark van bommel on se demandait un
moment s'il n'allait pas rester coincés
là dedans les russes ont accepté de le
redescendre finalement pour l'instant
même si elle a un peu contrainte et
forcée la station spatiale
internationale est un peu le dernier
endroit où les russes collabore toujours
avec les occidentaux et on se rappelle
qu il y a deux ans pour les 20 ans de la
station spatiale avait émergé une idée
qu'on avait pu trouver un petit peu
farfelu à savoir proposer les ss pour le
prix nobel de la paix peut-être que si
la coopération entre russes et
occidentaux se maintient vraiment sur la
durée pendant la durée du conflit c'est
peut-être une idée qui risque de refaire
surface